we are mix right we are black and white
we are French and Cuban and we have this
African culture when your mom is untold
[Music]
you really feel like all of that is what
makes us
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Danny beers I am Melissa
condi and we are eBay eBay means twins
in Yoruba my twenties I did the piano
parts and melody the lyrics I do all the
action and rhythm basically I did a
skeleton and she gives it the flesh and
the skin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we grew up listening to French artist
and old soul singers Yoruba chants
[Music]
Yoruba comes from Nigerian mean and
whence they were shipped to Cuba their
culture remained Cuban
our mother took us to Europa choir for
the first time we were 15 and we fell in
love with their songs and we are stage
every night singing those songs we're
honored to be part of this culture it's
almost like we are sponges so we take
everything in and it mixes up inside our
bellies and then it comes back and it
sounds like really it's really weird
it truly is like that
[Music]
this is our song deathless from our
second album ash normally I come to the
studio with the piano and the melody and
the lyrics but this time it started with
the beat and with the bass
it's heavy and dark
now meet and Richard Russell our
producer both created this object
[Music]
deafness is a really important song in
our album we wanted people to understand
the power they have - ooh
when I was 16 I got stopped in the
subway by policeman
and they were like do you smoke and I
said no new Malay to use drugs and I
said no do you drink and I said no and
then there were like are you effing
kidding me
and really really close to my face I
didn't understand obviously he was a
racist and then he made me take out my
socks and my shoes he took my bag and
threw everything on the floor like that
but when he saw I had a huge book I was
reading Anna Karenina he froze gave me
my empty bag back and left and then I
forgot about it but when our producer
Richard Russell asked us to want to
write a song about it
I said I can't my story's like nothing
and now me said something incredible I
said that it's wrong and it was already
enough and she shouldn't talk about it
so after having this be in my ears I
started writing the lyrics on exactly
what this policeman said to me
what sue me
[Music]
we realized that actually what we wanted
to do was an anthem for everybody to
feel deathless to feel immortal for
three minutes for everybody to feel like
one and to fill their own power and we
created that
[Music]
flesh
we are desolate but usually what we do
is we loop our own voices over and over
and over again because it's an anthem we
need other voices so we call this
amazing choir and we all sang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
even the sound guy even Richard Russell
our producer our mother was there we all
sang weird FS together and it was an
incredible experience so once we had the
beat and actually the melody and the
lyrics we went back to the studio and
you are the two dramas that's or that
you were like we grew up with our father
being one of the stars of a Latin jazz
world a master of the percussion well or
father died before I left that same you
we were like okay let's try to make them
when she played the Cajon for the first
time there's something that happened and
we all felt it every sight this is it it
was not just the rhythm it was lived our
fathers genes were in her it was almost
like you had played for years already
I play the Cajon or the better come on
it's what we use for Yoruba traditional
ceremony in Cuba really badass
made out of skin my master miguel by
Ambrosio he does have with wood so he
made this for me I really like to mix
electronic sounds and some wood and so I
just find that rhythm
it could be one day and a hip-hop beat
that she actually
deconstructs oh it could be a pop beat
but it also can be a traditional pattern
from the Yoruba culture we found a bass
sound when we combine voices traditional
drums and wood and electronics and this
is when it all clicks
[Music]
there's some songs that are really hard
to do and there's some songs and you
don't know why it's almost magical
everything fits and that's what that's
always our whole love for music it's
mixing we are proud to mix everything
for it to still feel that it comes from
your heart music rise a power that has
no boundaries
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]